welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host Chris and helping the
first this is a very guess what exciting
episode our Lady Jaye is here with us if
you don't know who she is educate
yourself goddamnit because she's been
educating everyone on everything she is
the most insanely wonderful elegant
person I think I've ever met she's an
award-winning writer a groundbreaking
activist she's won a Peabody Award she's
just she writes on Poe's transparent she
pushes her dogs around in strollers at
art museums
she does it all and she has the most
calming voice that you will ever hear so
even if you don't retain any of the
information from this episode I
encourage you to listen to it all the
way through because it is so soothing I
forgot where I was for most of the time
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
our Lady Jaye excuse you
do you have a great idea that you'd like
to turn into a reality well then I have
a company that can help you do it it's
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you want to showcase your work
or sell products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything so you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself but if you get stuck they have
24/7 award-winning customer support that
is there to help you out
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain yesterday morning I woke up I
took like gummy vitamins and then I got
extremely extremely exhausted I was like
why did I get so tired I don't know
maybe I'm just overworked whatever and
then this morning I went to take the
same gummy vitamins and I realized that
it was gummy melatonin and so I had
taken like 10 gummy melatonin yesterday
morning and then was just like a zombie
walking around my husband like I I guess
I just roofied myself by accident yeah
but so you're wearing your Fitbit to
monitor your sleep to monitor my sleep
cuz I've just been so like tired and
like why am I tired because I'm old yes
also what is going on yeah and then I
found out I've only been sleeping like 4
to 5 hours I'm sleeping really a so I've
been limit
my coffee the caffeine yeah helping but
then I've been dealing with depression
because of my lack of capital yeah and
the headaches and all of it like the
withdrawal is real yeah I don't know how
to dose myself in life what's your
what's been like the most embarrassing
max cuz I can say for myself I've I've
gotten through a period of time where I
was having like four Red Bulls a day
throughout the day and then going like
I'm not sleeping at night but the Red
Bull has nothing to do with it um I
would say like four or five a day is
like my max yeah Alfie today I'm on two
coffees because I wanted to have some
sort of personality with you
[Laughter]
we were talking right before you're in
the middle of writing right now yes okay
so to walk me through this the process
for pose which I watched the pilot and
it's [ __ ] phenomenal and I love it so
am I thank you so you're in the middle
at season two comes out in a couple
months June 9 June 9 FX on FX
and so what's the process right now that
you're in so we're writing and we're
shooting at the same time Oh which is
like the clock is ticking right thank
you for being well so we have about half
the season written right now okay and
we're just filming episode two right now
okay so we have ten episodes this season
which is 2 more than last cool exciting
yes um so while we're filming in New
York one of our writers Janet mock is in
New York who are you seeing on set yeah
and then the rest of us Ryan Murphy Brad
Falchuk Steven house and myself are out
here finishing the scripts and then
we'll change up the writers like Steven
will go to New York or I'll go to New
York and we we take turns producing on
set cool and we keep the writers room
going until the scripts are finished and
what in the most layman's terms
what's a writers room like for people
that want to get into that sort of world
but and you hear the term writers room
and you see it like parodied on like 30
rock and things like that
what's an actual in your experienced
writers room like it's cut while I was a
musician before your yeah your piano is
unreal thank you
well you know I learned that playing a
classical piano is kind of like owning a
VCR store it's like it's fun but no
one's coming so I learned the television
a lot of people watch moved to
television and I saw I relate to
everything to music yeah it's kind of
like playing a band we're in a writers
room the pose writers room is only five
people so it's pretty small okay
transparent um went from like eight to
ten people depending on the season Wow
so um you learn to play your part you're
like oh I'm really good at doing this so
when when that's when it's my turn for
example for transparent I was the only
trans person in the writers room we're
just four seasons and I went and trans
to everything up which is great because
it adds a necessary level of like
authenticity to a script Thanks yeah and
that's what I the showrunners are kind
of like the conductors or the I don't
know the band leaders sure you know they
bring a group of people in together um
and hopefully it fits together like a
nice puzzle right and propose um I feel
like the thing that I really lean into
are like the hiv/aids storylines and
yeah as a former New Yorker I was in New
York for ten years yeah and so a lot of
my transistors came from the ballroom
community oh wow you know taught me to
be the woman I am today
yeah so you know we all lean in in
different areas on the writers room oh
that's so interesting I mean do you have
goofs and spoofs in the writers room too
it feels like you guys are tackling a
lot of heavy issues but you're allowed
you are also bringing a sense of like
seriousness and levity at the same time
so that to me is so interesting to
balance like making things feel real but
also not taking yourself so seriously
like finding the comedy in certain
moments and finding the sincerity in
others you have a lot of laughter and
the music in the fashion is a big part
yes so you know we're always you to
being like a flashback to the 80s in
having a moment your turn are we
private dancer last season was one of
the songs that we used in a montage and
so as I was writing that scene I was
just like playing private dancer that's
amazing so wit how do you make the move
from you know being so focused on music
to writing I mean it must feel like
there's parallels and similarities in
the way you compose something versus the
way you compose a script for sure well
it's all storytelling yeah you know you
have your audience in mind as you're
writing sorry I'm just looking at
Jennifer Aniston's I know I have to look
at it like a blurry magic eye because if
I like focused too hard unlike some of
the people that have signed this table I
lose my mouth pretty incredible yeah
stargazing music translates like from
writing composing and performing to now
writing scripts and that situation like
how did you move from one area to the
other so you're always thinking about
your audience right you know no matter
who you are as a performer as a writer
but you're also thinking about the
content that you're creating and the
experience that you had that relates to
that content and then relating to the
audience because art is reflection right
yeah people turn to art people turn to
entertainment to see themselves and to
validate their experiences yeah that's
psychologically what I believe happens
in art mm-hmm and so with music it's
it's quicker because you have the
audience of live performance there yeah
so you have a reaction with television
though you kind of have to anticipate
what their reaction is gonna be so you
have to stay awake a lot more culture of
what's happening right now yeah so I
find I'm just a lot more tuned into you
know I'm on Twitter which I don't enjoy
okay that was gonna be my next line of
questioning about like your relationship
with social media because I think we're
all in a very flux stage of like it's it
can be powerful and helpful and it can
be completely toxic and discouraging at
the same time and you I mean like I
always deep dive into every guest kind
of like social media presence and you
are so pure and wonderful and good
I'm curious as to like yeah hearing that
you hate Twitter I just don't want to
get in trouble I'm very conservative on
Twitter really I'm like here's my
project
yes it's very presentational it's not
like soap boxes but yeah I'd like to put
my personality more into my art you know
I yeah and my art right now is
television you know it was music it you
know I'm sure it's gonna change again
I'm working on a feature right now oh
cool so I have all these different
things so I'd like to anytime I have an
urge to reach out and just like scream
on social media I put it in my art
that's a great rule that I think
everyone could kind of take and put in
their back pocket I specific in a way
that I think is appropriate and
necessary because I saw that the Oscars
like fashion thing one you looked
[ __ ] stunning thank you and someone
put you on a worst dressed list yeah
which made no sense to me because the
dress you're wearing like emerald green
like beautiful like architectural dress
I thought was fabulous thank you and I
really agree didn't wear it if I didn't
think I looked good in it and I love
that you actually were just like this
isn't like a fair assessment of this
situation right now well it was my first
time at the Golden Globes and I had
written on transparent which had won a
Golden Globe nominated for Golden Globes
but this is my first time at the actual
ceremony okay so I was so happy to be
there that here I'm a writer I'm a
producer on a hit show yeah I'm a trans
woman yeah like do you have any idea how
hard I've worked to get to space we all
work to go into those rooms every person
that is at an award show has worked
really hard to get there hmm so to have
women walk a red carpet and then judge
what they're wearing is so infuriating
yeah
and it's such residue of the patriarchy
yeah it's like unnecessary it's not
where we're going anymore we're not
judging each other by how we look I
think it's important to celebrate
fashion yes because that can be really
fun and that's a beautiful art form in
itself to celebrate people who really
love the way they look we love that
dress but
put me on a goddamn worst dress but you
came for them in such a politely
elegantly respectful way that it wasn't
even like [ __ ] you [ __ ] just
like okay here's the real like behind
the scenes of how difficult it is for me
like fine things that work for myself
and like make me feel confident and I
thought that was just like a very
elegant way of being like no no you have
no real idea what is a writer I feel
like I look at everyone as kind of being
naive I really I really don't think
people are awful
I think people are misguided and so
that's a very moment wonderful way to
see it conservatively nicely I think so
because I've seen people grow so much
yeah a lifetime if really seen the trans
movement take off and I've seen people's
hearts and minds change yeah so I know
that that's possible so even if it's
something petty like a dress I know
someone is like going through it and me
feeling insecure about their own life
there's a lot of projection I think that
happens in those situations why not
educate yeah I think that's a beautiful
way to put it okay so you just went to
the GLAAD Awards you're a member of the
GLAAD board I am
congratulations that's very awesome and
very cool and you went and Beyonce was
in the room Beyonce was in the room how
close did you get to the bay I did not i
watch I immediately the next morning
because my friend Hannah was there and I
heard shangela perform like a full
Beyonce thing and I furiously just like
tired I am like Google YouTube like give
me Angela's performance and it was
incredible how was it was incredible it
was well first of all I want to give a
shout out to Lissa yes my new favorite
musician like she is doing everything
like read music to do mm-hmm I just when
she comes down plays like flu the flu
imagine this is the real deal yeah I'm
here for huh huh am I allowed to curse
on this [ __ ] course you can I'm
always like how many
bombs can I put in a script oh yeah
still don't understand the rules
but anyway so Lizza was amazing and then
shangela came on and performed at first
everyone thought it was Beyonce cuz you
hear the music right oh my god yeah
and then it's shangela and everyone's
freaking out because Beyonce's there
watch oh my god she was incredible I
can't imagine the pressure of performing
Beyonce in front of Beyonce I can't
either
oh that's so bonkers but the awards
overall were a great time a great time I
think it was Gladys best event ever
really have another award show coming up
in New York May 4th
oh I don't know it's gonna be on Irwin
oh my god freaking out trying to hold
myself back cuz I know I'm just gonna
run up to her and say mommy mommy thank
you yeah I mean I think it's okay you
are it seems incredibly busy and your
brain works in so many fascinating
wonderful ways what do you do to like
for free time if you have any I have
dogs and so yeah you have two dogs dogs
okay Nachi and TC TC short for
Tchaikovsky amazing they're both just
really gay classical musician I spend
time with them you know hiking I have a
little dog stroller that I take oh no
you walk them in a stroller okay walk me
through the decision to get the dog
stroller well I love going to museums
people freak out when you bring dogs to
museum and so I didn't want my dogs my
children I didn't want my children to
hold back my lifestyle you know
experience in culture yeah so I know
that I can take them on a hike that's
easy obviously I can walk them through
us Hollywood but taking them to the get
here's the situation and so I see all of
these like cisgender folks with their
babies in their strollers enjoying their
life
I think well I should just get a
stroller for my dogs it's so I'd
literally just put my daughter oh okay
sometimes some will look in this Charlie
hands he put their two animals in there
which honestly probably are way quieter
than a baby wouldn't be in a stroller
favorite Museum veggetti
for sure yeah they appreciate the
Baroque era I've had my friend sneak her
tiny dog into a hotel swaddled like a
baby because it was a not a dog friendly
hotel so I understand the correlation of
it is it is a do they make strollers for
dogs did you do it's a stroller for dogs
okay yeah but it looks like a baby
stroller - it looks like a baby stroller
it packs up into my Mini Cooper oh my
god also these are great life hacks for
anyone that you know feels like held
back by their fur babies I'm talking
like you don't have to leave them at
home or you don't have to stay at home
exactly how old are they
Liberace eight with her both rescues so
it's hard to tell sure you can tell by
their teeth ish yeah actually it's
really bad to you we think he's like
five mm-hmm and TC she was rescued from
a meat factory in Korea oh wow we think
she's around - how did that happen
there's an activist who comes over I'm
blanking on her name right now but she
works with dogs Without Borders okay
and she convinces she educates the meat
factory zone like why you shouldn't eat
dogs Wow and um and then rescues the
dogs when they release the dogs from the
factory Wow things them over are all
around the world and then people rescue
these dogs wow that's incredible a
little bit of PTSD
I'm sure yeah I understand both this
like that's a very intense intense but
incredible line of work to be doing yeah
it's she's she's really great Hey Wow
Leticia it's been a slow journey slow
journey by healing with my own PTSD heal
with her PTSD and
Vidia paradox and that's you know art
heels in a way I'm glad they're getting
out there okay we're gonna take a really
quick break but when I get back we have
more questions for our Lady Jaye
I'm not your deep we'll be right back
[Music]
not too deep is brought to you by one of
my favorite brands third love with more
than 70 sizes including their signature
half cup sizes third love designs bras
with breast size and shape in mind for
perfect fit and premium feel you just
answer a few simple questions on their
third loves fit finder quiz to find your
perfect fit in like 60 seconds then
thinks the third loves 100% fit
guarantee you can wear wash and put your
bra to the test for 60 days and if you
don't love it you can return it and
third level wash it and donate it to a
woman in need this is hands-down the
most comfortable bra that you'll ever
own
they have straps that don't slip they
have tag list labels it's lightweight
super thin memory foam cups I mean it's
got it all and I always say this I love
this company because they truly have
convinced me that I don't just need to
wear sports bras every day because I am
a creature of comfort and have it and
they are truly truly the most
comfortable actual bras that I've ever
worn they know that there's a perfect
fit for everyone so right now they're
offering you beautiful listeners 15% off
your first order go to 3rd love comm
slash grace now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love th IRD l.o.v.e comm
slash grace for 15% off today oh are you
ready to turn your dream into a reality
well then guess what today's sponsor
Squarespace can help you do that they
make it easier than ever for you to
launch your passion project do you want
to start a business showcase work
published content sell products for more
they are the tool for you they have
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself plus
they have a powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and they offer analytics
that help you grow your site in real
time plus everything is optimized for
mobile
right out of the box there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever whatever that
means
I don't even know buying domains is
super simple and you'll get the help you
need if you need it with their 24/7
award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people designers to
lawyers artists to gamers restaurants
gyms you can turn your great ideas into
something real go to squarespace.com
slash grace for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch use offer code
grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain that's
squarespace.com slash grace offer code
grace let's talk about Dolly Parton how
did that you have a pure friendship with
Dolly Parton how did this session turned
into a cease and desist so I was
performing these songs in New York when
I was a singer/songwriter in New York
doing that whole thing yeah I I did this
concert once a year called the gospel of
Dolly oh man because Dolly was a big
part of my childhood my grandma loved
her and you know I'm a hillbilly and
from like a village of 200 people like
Amish Mennonite you're in Pennsylvania
okay yeah we're in Pennsylvania southern
central so it's the northern tip of the
Appalachian mountain oh wow okay in
valley around okay my brother went to
Carnegie Mellon okay um I've driven from
Manhattan to you pity burger yeah and
you not to say that I don't come and
play but there is a weird like southern
kind of vibe in Pennsylvania they don't
think a lot of people know pencil
talkie-talkie
mm-hmm so I'm from that area okay where
I mean I'm a billionaire but it's very
different than you know coastal city
living sure so when I was in New York I
was I decided to sing these dolly songs
she has these amazing gospel songs that
don't have any religious dogma to them
you're just all about like lifting
everyone up loving and having a good
time in life yeah so my dear friend
Stephen Remus me
directed her nine-to-five Broadway show
oh wow and gave her a copy of a bootleg
of my concert along with like an article
that paralleled our lives that first
from Time Out New York amazing and then
my album uh-huh and she listened to it
and her tour bus oh and then asked to
meet me and I swear I thought she was
gonna hand me a cease and desist what's
your reaction when you hear that Dolly
Parton wants to meet you I was teaching
at the time so this is in 2008 or 2009
okay um
ten years ago oh my god Wow and I was
teaching and I just looked at my phone
and I got the text and I just excuse
myself I have to attend a dolly parton
so wait it was the text and meet right
now and that was just all he wants to
meet you yes school Brendon so I met
dolly like the next week um and she was
just so gracious and kind and she wanted
to thank me for singing her songs she
went through the set list of like what
her favorite songs were about each song
she's just so present she's like the
Buddha you really feel like Buddha when
you're with her because she's so secure
and she is yeah yeah and that translates
to generosity
mm-hmm a hundred percent she yeah its
she's one of those people that you hope
is as like genuinely wonderful as you
imagine her debate really us assets so
and then she actually later like a year
later I had a fundraiser called boob aid
for my boobs yeah um yeah I donated
that's by tens that she autographed and
we auctioned everything off online
because was before Kickstarter yeah Tori
Amos donated something RuPaul that's the
O'Donnell incredible the community came
together for the people
yeah these are the most famous set of
tips we the full disclosure I'm on my
second pair now that was the first okay
well they like in a shadowbox make your
own tiny Smithsonian in your house and
be amazing oh my gosh that's incredible
so went how long ago did you move out to
Los Angeles nine years ago nine years
ago and how was it going from New York
to LA um I felt like New York was going
through like a bedbug a moment I got
bedbugs in New York in 2010 oh my god I
lived off the Marcy jmz stop for three
months and my roommate and I literally
got bedbugs and then I ended up moving
to Park Slope for the last three years
but I trusted nothing after an etching
right now I seem here it just I I left
New York during the bedbug yeah I left
everything I left my piano there you did
literally started everything over wow I
just needed a fresh break yeah did you
come here with any sort of job
opportunities or no just kind of came
here Klein and like blind I actually put
everything in trash bags and my parents
barn started everything new and then
eventually moved the things that I
wanted sure sure sure
how would you describe your experience
in New York oh you were there for ten
years
yeah I was there for ten years yeah at
first you know New York is for either
young or rich folks yes that's exactly
correct I am so glad that I lived in New
York first and then came to Elex I think
if I came to LA first I'm from New
Jersey originally that I don't think I
would have been like risky enough to go
to New York because it's stress it's a
very stressful city to live in it is so
it was fun like I was there I moved
there when I was 21 and I felt like I
lived the life that I wanted to live
there the debauchery the scandals all of
it yes and then and then that got kind
of tiring I
really tired lift to LA and I realized I
hadn't slept in ten years now you have
your Fitbit because it's happening again
good reason down yeah not for
desperation reasons now what do what
what's been like I know you've been
going based on your Instagram you go to
a lot of Hollywood parties what is your
relationship with like bougie Hollywood
party situations Oh Lord it feels like
well I'm always curious to know cuz I
feel like everyone always has a story of
either embarrassing themselves or like
seeing someone across the room that they
can't believe or just like the sheer
insanity of all of it
it feels like a lot of pressure to
represent yes there are very few trans
people who are invited to these spaces
and so I feel like a real gratitude when
I walk into them it's like wow I get to
do this yeah you know I'm I'm doing the
work I'm also representing my community
so I just don't want to [ __ ] up right
and then I realized that that stress is
just too much and I just need to like
let that go yeah I'd have fun that's
good hopefully I try to have fun but I'm
also sober so I'm not really that much
fun situations are just so compounded
stress regardless that everything else
that you have to represent there it's
just like I can't even imagine what's
working right like networking I'm like
trying to talk to the most powerful
producers as powerful directors they're
the most famous people so it feels a
little weird my hillbilly ass not really
about good at faking things because I'm
just a hillbilly I see that's what I
relate to more than if you put on this
air being like a fully and like
self-important Hollywood [ __ ] well
totally but then you're also wearing
like these gorgeous gowns and that's
true too I guess like it's just like a
really traumatic thing in you and
how sure the night you're like what was
that I just got hit by a train it's a
fever dream it's a total fever dream is
there a question that you hate getting
asked the most or that you're just so
over answering well for a while people
just asked about surgeries all the time
yeah um but the the trans activists have
kind of educated the world about that oh
and which is great um so journalists
don't really ask me that anymore that's
good it's nice yeah but I'm happy to
offer up you know who the best plastic
surgeon is yeah how do you even go about
finding the right person for that um
just like for Emily's have confessed a
lot to me really ain't because my trans
missus visible mm-hm
and it's obvious that I have been to
doctors sure because I'm a six foot two
trans woman right and this beauty did
not come from God to me and they just
because it's so hush-hush in Hollywood
where you like you don't talk about your
surgery you don't talk about it because
there's a lot of stigma and like I'm
naturally beautiful but a lot of women
have come up to me and told me
everything
really I hold a lot of Secrets full
Pandora's box
I know other doctors to go to oh that's
amazing
okay what because you act as well I kind
of write myself cameos because I think
it's like a nice Alfred Hitchcock thing
for me to do mm-hmm
like in transparent I was in season two
I was in the flashback of Berlin as a
cabaret pianist oh that's great season
four I was in a flashback of 1980s trans
pageant classical pianist cerveza man in
season one of pose I was a I was into
aids cabaret uh-huh
like this Jim you're like Broadway
pianist so that's like myself these like
weird pianists also you kind of
stereotype yourself
itself lines every time and somehow they
always piano player says something like
this I don't know we get to play this
part we didn't even write any alliance
and her name was Cheryl Lynn uh-huh so
Cheryl Lynn didn't have any lines but in
the moment there was this weird moment
with MJ who plays a Blanca she comes
over the piano and she's like she had
this in your book and I was like oh wait
I don't have any alliance I think mm-hmm
but the mic didn't pick it up so I
actually had to ADR which must be the
most weirdly like oddly stressful thing
to like line up your mouth making those
noises I did like four different takes
backstory is there is there a project or
like a genre of something that you
haven't worked on yet that you would
love to do I want to do a thriller so oh
really
yes I feel like my life is a
psychological thriller scream wait how
so just you know maneuvering in the
world today is scary yeah or it can be
scary and it can be really exciting as
well yeah and I've always looked at you
know Andy Warhol always talked about
like looking at life like a movie like
you're in a movie and how that takes
away anxiety and I did that from a
really young age I'm when I was looking
at like the bully is on the playground
yeah like well I'm in the movie I'm
gonna be a star I'm the underdog and I'm
gonna exceed all expectations yeah and
just the Swan I'm gonna become a swan
Sanji and I felt like like having that
narrative in my life has really helped
me yeah get through tough times that's
so interesting it's such a very creative
way to think about that that seems very
helpful I think my therapist you know
probably has diagnosed that is something
like this is not the way that you should
be handling this
we should be surprised we should be
handling trauma head-on okay but with
that with the horror thriller be
musically enjoying working on I'm
working on a play right now actually
cool um I can't say too much no no where
is it's about a classical musician and
you know there's murder involved in
historical fiction
and so it's turning into it like a
little bit of a psychological thriller
but knowing me it'll just probably turn
into a weepy drama in my head it's a sex
glad to go through with it
that's just really sad what um is there
anything that you watch like guilty I
hate calling a guilty pleasure because I
always like because I love reality
television that's like my escapism but
is there anything that you watch that's
like completely different than what you
work on that's just for you to relax um
for me to relax or just to like you're
like um I don't know I I'm on Instagram
a lot and I oh yes okay videos about
eyebrows cool yeah okay let's talk about
this and who do you follow like who's
like your go-to person that you look at
on Instagram um I don't have a like a
go-to person I go to the search area
because it likes explore page algorithms
yeah so well it only shows me drag
queens and like teenage makeup tutorials
where like a ms/ms or ASMR yeah I Assam
which I was gonna say you have just
hearing your voice in the headphones
yeah does that affect you and it does a
little bit
tinkles I was gonna say you have a voice
that's like perfect for being an ASMR
Thank You person and nauseous years this
testosterone well if you get sick of
writing you have a backup career who
need to cuz it's very trendy right now
I enjoy this video that's a lot yeah I
mean that's I think the most accurate
way to find out about a person is to
look at the
Instagram explorer page because it
really just reflects what's they're
interested in totally and sometimes
minded look at and I go who are you like
what happened when did this become this
a friend of mine complained to me
recently he's like I only see like
mostly men on my Instagram because
that's you you only look at mostly man
your phone is tracking all the things
that you like and presenting them back
to you to try and please your you know
visually just comment on a lot of
dragonss am i yeah do you have a
favorite drag queen or like I couldn't
possibly yeah it's too much yes fame I
really love I love everything she's
doing in the world like an anesthetic
elegance and just like composure an
actual artistic talent yes I watch her
YouTube tutorials of makeup tutorials
all the time and it's so she's always
just so composed she and John yes - she
sent me a couple of them and they're
like the magnetic lit like lids uh I was
like why don't why doesn't every
lipstick do this that's amazing and
they're so beautiful like to know
they're packaged they're packaged so so
elegantly it makes me feel like I'm more
capable than I am just like having them
in my house okay we're gonna take one
last break and when we get back we have
a bunch of Twitter questions for you if
you do not mind okay inquiring minds
want to know your least favorite social
media platform is resource let's get
something straight
I'm talking about your teeth no offense
but if you got offended by that then
listen up the smile direct Club
straightens your teeth for sixty percent
less than braces with clear liners sent
directly to you you go online and book a
free 3d image at one of their smile
shops or order an at-home impression kit
and you will be emailed a preview of
your new smile once you get your
aligners one of the smile direct club's
duly licensed doctors will check in on
your progress every 90 days most new
smiles take six months on average visits
smile direct Club calm for real before
and after photos from some
they're 550 thousand plus satisfied grin
errs okay you heard that number right
let that sink in five hundred and fifty
thousand plus satisfied grin nurse again
get a free 3d image of your smile I
would have smile direct clubs
smile shops or a twenty five dollar
rebate on an at-home impression kit and
then just for our listeners you can
receive $100 off your clear liners when
you go to smile direct Club comm slash
podcast and use the offer code grace 100
again that's $100 off at smile direct
club.com slash podcast offer code grace
one zero zero smile direct club.com such
podcast offer code grace 102 deep
support for today's show comes from Bare
Minerals creators of clean beauty purity
and formulation and uncompromising
performance have always been the guiding
principles of bare minerals because they
believe that makeup and skin care should
make your skin better not just better
looking take a second and let that seep
in like their beautiful
bare mineral makeup this has been their
philosophy since they began the clean of
beauty revolution in 1995 with their
best-selling original foundation which
offers creamy lightweight buildable
coverage that's naturally luminous the
clean formula is made with only 5 good
for skin ingredients surprised they're
all minerals including non-chemical SPF
protection makeup so pure you can sleep
in it and Lord knows I've fall asleep in
it whether makeup companies want me to
or not but it's great to know that I
actually can with bare minerals and it
actually improves your skin over time
it's everything that your skin needs and
nothing it doesn't for bare minerals to
be clean without compromise means good
for skin formulas with proven
performance like every bare minerals
product it's 100% cruelty free and
better yet both the original and matte
loose powder foundations are available
in 30 shades so upgrade to clean beauty
products use the foundation finder at
bare minerals calm to find your perfect
match first time customers will get 15%
off when you use the promo code not too
deep that's bare minerals calm promo
code not
too deep for 15% off your first purchase
Bare Minerals the power of good okay we
are back and before we get into these
Twitter questions I'm gonna ask you the
two questions I asked every single guest
those on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at oh gosh yeah
very intense oh wow it's probably like
someone from my past like gay people
deserved AIDS yeah and a lot of my
trauma comes from having to go to church
three times a week of the child three
times a week three times a week well I'm
doing these derogatory comments made
about who I was yeah um you know they
didn't have the word for trans back then
but I'm sure if they did he would have
been preaching against it so I want to
throw cold spaghetti
I would love to witness that firsthand
that would be incredible okay the other
question is to tell us your worst pants
shooting story or like a close call
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases interchange like
some mine is a college jogging front
lawn and it could be a closer it's gonna
get dark it's never happened to me
really dark hate spills newly diagnosed
late for work for 16 years
yeah I'm undetectable and I am proud HIV
odd advocate an activist because I want
people to know that it's no longer the
death sentence that it used to be yeah
undetectable is also untranslatable so
like we can [ __ ] and you're not gonna
get it from right right I'm not to me to
anyone right now people need to hear
that kind of yeah cuz I think the
biggest misconception what would you say
the biggest misconception is it's
dangerous and you're this pariah to
society and you're gonna be dead in a
minute but it's just not true you can we
live a long and healthy life and I'm
putting this out there mostly for the
men that I date
and not be afraid to go out and a date
with me yeah I think that that's so
important I was seeing a couple articles
recently or within the last year of you
being so much more vocal about that and
that's in the first episode of pose yeah
you know and so I was like this is
really helpful because I do think that a
lot of people it's just hearsay and then
they believe beliefs rather than facts
and they freak out and I've seen it so
many times with like I've had a lot of
important connections with men that have
ended because of the stigma around
hiv/aids
so you know it's personal you must be
exhausted constantly educating people
that is hugely important and I hope that
that continues the momentum of allowing
people to understand it and educate
themselves on it rather than just assume
totally but sixteen years ago the meds
were not as good as they are today
[Laughter]
someone's - no thoughts on RuPaul's Drag
Race do you think it's helping people be
more open minded towards the idea of
transgenderism transgenderism that's the
word they use oh I like that word I said
an actual word I don't think that's an
actual word but I like it um I think all
the content that we can get out there
that has that is LGBT focus or LGBT Qi a
inclusive is helping every part of the
community so obviously yeah I think that
um drag race is helping people
understand their relationship to gender
which therefore helps them be more open
to a trans person yeah I think that's
great
I mean it's the same way that you kind
of focus a lot of your personal life
experience into the storytelling that
you do it's always been so impactful for
me when I watched drag race to just hear
personal stories everyone's personal
story and really realize how much more
complicated and different every person
story is yeah and gia Gunn did a lot of
work on the last all-stars yeah
explaining the difference between drag
and transness yeah Alvis two can
intersect and and come together I think
that was really great so I'm excited to
see where it goes from here someone just
asked what is love what is whoa that is
a beautiful thing to say yeah I believe
that's true you should put that in a
song somewhere no when's the last time
you went to the dentist um a month ago
oh god bless I just literally reminded
me that I haven't been in like a year
and a half I'm gonna take care of my
teeth good it's a recent thing if you
like recently employed wish what's your
what is your because self-care is
something that I think a lot of people
focus on now it's becoming very not
trendy is the right word but it's just
becoming necessary what's your like
go-to self-care
I have an eight-step skin care regimen
usually was four steps in the morning
four steps at night cleaner uh-huh a
different cleaner morning different
cleaner at night okay in the morning I
use an exfoliating cleanser and then at
night I use an oil-based cleanser okay
and then the second step is toner which
I use both the same morning and night
and then the third step is a serum and
in the morning I use like a redness
reducing serum okay and then at night I
use like a skin cell regenerating so oh
and then the fourth step is moisturizer
and in the morning I use an SPF based
moisturizer and at night I use a thicker
mask there you guys are my eight steps I
mean eight sounds like a lot but then
when you break it down I'm like that
seems pretty common-sense I'm like oh
man I gotta really invest in since my
forties so think well you don't look a
day over 29 how dare you I guess it
works someone to notice Billy Porter's
red carpet tux dress double as a tepee
is that what's meant by cam I think so I
think that's why can't means it me that
you can be with an LGBT person in the
wilderness and you're gonna survive I
love that look so much mica did you saw
read up I did I love Billy first of all
yes a human being and as an artist and
now as a fashion icon oh my god and also
I was just shocked that we had never
seen anything like that before
oh yeah I was shocked that it was so
shocking I guess because I was just like
this is perfect this is wonderful I love
this yeah um I love I love the look and
I also like to think that maybe it would
house would double as housing or maybe
like the Nutcracker like in the
grandmother in the Nutcracker all the
ballerinas come out from under the dress
like full-on performances or at least
just the devil's is Airbnb for someone
ya know most underrated fast food chain
are you a fast food but I don't eat fast
food good for you
what's your like guilty pleasure food
then chocolate-covered pretzels really
whoa
that's specific yeah I like the salty
and the sweet to balance to balance it
all out carbs and I'm allergic to gluten
so I'm technically allergic to white
sugar as well they came sugar geez and
so I just have a full on realize almost
no best taco you've ever eaten I like
fish tacos okay I also like fish tacos
pretty great thoughts on Taylor Swift um
Taylor Swift I love that she's becoming
more vocal with her politics yeah I
agree
2016 election I was glad she did that
it's really rare for pop stars to do
that because they really have such a
broad audience that they risk losing a
lot yeah that was really brave of her
and I like that she just donated like
millions of dollars to this LGBT
organization I saw that yeah Tennessee
was it yeah it was something yes
recently um and I heard my friend I
heard Tyler Oakley talk about on a
podcast
and I was like oh that's fantastic so
she's putting her money where her mouth
is
yeah is there a music artist that you
would want to collaborate with that you
haven't yet Whitney Houston uh anyone
that is still alive currently with us
I've been lucky to work with so many
people that I love mm-hmm so I'm trying
to think well I just mentioned Liz oh
how much I love her
yeah is that with her I mean that seems
like a collaboration that should happen
the piano the flute the soul singing
piano I would love that
let's go call me for your elbow
someone says how do you get a cool
chosen name to stick
oh that's cool well I have two chosen
names so I had my birth name and then I
changed my name legally to another name
and then I have my pseudonym which is
registered with the WGA and the
television Academy and sag which is our
Lady Jaye yeah and I think any name that
you want to stick you just have to
repeat it and then kind of hide the
other name so I don't even tell people
my legal name really friends know my
legal name I don't think people at work
even know here's my legal name I'm sure
Ryan Murphy does but he's never called
me that yeah they call me Jay they call
me lady Jay how did our Lady Jaye come
to be I was reading Our Lady of the
flowers Oh awesome three uh-huh and was
just in love with these characters and I
knew that I was gonna be transitioning
shortly good you know I was more along
the spectrum of gender less in the
binary than I am now um and so I wanted
our lady something and my birth name was
a Jay Hey and I knew I wanted to change
my legal name to a Jay so I stuck with
the Jay oh so it all came from you it
wasn't given by someone else or
influenced by someone else I wish I had
like some like drag mother in the
community he gave it to me but no I was
just reading a book by myself and I gave
it to me I love that art comes from
everywhere
someone asked what is it like getting to
be part of such a groundbreaking
history-making show was the way of the
importance of it overbearing or did it
help drive everyone I don't want to
sound like an [ __ ] but do they mean
transparent or opposed because I've been
lucky to be on to I think I mean they
don't say specifically I may be posed
cuz that's the newest yeah I would say
posed I mean do you because it is so
important do you find that the weight of
wanting to make something you know so
true to yourself overwhelming or is that
more of a motivating que me overwhelming
for sure you have to learn how to deal
with that yeah with the pressure um you
know if I sit down in front of a blank
screen and think about the millions of
people that are gonna hear my words yeah
I'm just gonna freeze that's terrifying
yeah I just have to put that out of my
mind I'm sure you know what this is like
when you when you make a youtube video
whenever you're doing a podcast yeah if
you overthink it too much then you'll
never create the thing that you really
yeah want to so you have to focus on
what you're making and then also see
yourself as not the center of it you're
just kind of being of service to
something that is much bigger than you
oh that's interesting that relieves any
nerves yeah that's a very great way to
think about it it's almost like musical
collaboration I imagine like you're part
of a band yeah it's actually not me yeah
I'm part of something and I get to do
this oh that's so great like I have to
do this and it's all about me do you
have a pumpup song that you listen to
when you're like getting ready to be
creative I only listen to gospel music a
lot you do really
what are your go-to Kurt Franklin um
because I'm not familiar with gospel
music at all but for anyone out there
that wants to like listen to anything I
think well a stand is my favorite okay
my favorite gospel song of all time okay
um but I don't know I also listen to the
preachers life soundtrack a lot I think
that yeah I look i listen to jock jams
everyone has their genre
okay what's next for you what's coming
up well we're getting postseason Shuai
and hopefully that will come back for a
season three he's very exciting because
you don't know yet right about season
three okay um but in the meantime I'm
developing two shows that I can't talk
about that's very exciting
ominous vague and exciting but as a
creator I'm developing these shows and
then the play that I'm working on and
then a little feature amazing there's
always things on the back burner yeah
and you're busy busy
you're being busy well thank you so much
for being here today before you leave we
give every guest that's made time for us
a personalized fortune cookie gosh this
is for you you can open it and read it
you don't have to eat it obviously
especially I don't see a fortune cranked
um oh how did you put this in here we
shoved it in there for sure
somewhere in this world there is a
private Catholic school that goes by Our
Lady Jaye but also a marijuana
dispensary is that true no not at all
you got it okay where can people find
you on social media online I promised my
jam Lady Jaye I'm on Twitter but I'm
pretty quiet and I'm really quiet on
Facebook follow me on Instagram and then
poses on FX FX coming out June 9 oh my
guys please go check out our Lady Jaye
she's absolutely wonderful and just like
a complete Renaissance woman thank you
again so much for being here so great
meeting ya vice versa and we'll see you
guys next time another sort of nacho
deep goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep
this episode of not too deep has been
brought to you by bare minerals as the
creators of clean Beauty bare minerals
is driven by a philosophy that makeup
and skincare should make your skin
better not just better looking and
that's why their best-selling original
foundation is made with only five
ingredients surprise surprise
they're all minerals for bare minerals
to be clean without compromise means
good for skin formulas with proven
performance so upgrade to clean beauty
products use the foundation finder at
bare minerals calm to find your perfect
match
all you first-time customers you will
get 15% off when you use the promo code
not too deep bareMinerals the power of
good not too deep as a production of
grace helbig incorporated producer and
edited by melissa Dumont's writing by
diane kang a production assistants by
Katrina Henning post-production sound by
Chris Henry and an extra special thanks
to Flula for the theme music
[Music]